how about you dad you got a girlfriend  no book no to tell your - Jason is white  - that's right maybe you should start  dating again no no no I'm all right as  is J and I'm doing just fine you're  saying probably be good for you  seems like mom is moving on her and  Gregor even talking about getting  married but they're talking about what  he hadn't officially asked her yet but  she knows it's coming they talk about it  all the time  she's ridiculous  ink on the divorce barely even dry well  I mean it has been two years but you  know what are you human calendar  mr. Trapper Keeper I know how long it's  been I hate selfish people I'll give it  to him Oh Greg told me something that  ideas he had for when he was gone for  post man that dude has a great  imagination he was talking about all  these crazy things like skydiving and  stuff where he go just take a leak  you